what is the council presidency and how
does it work the council presidency is
responsible for driving forward the
council's work each member state is
called upon in turn to take on this role
and ensure continuity in the council's
agenda the council presidency has
several key tasks it pans and chairs
meetings of the ministers and working
groups of civil servants discussing EU
legislation in the council but in the
case of Foreign Affairs it is the EU
High Representative for foreign and
security policy who plans and chairs
meetings the presidency also represents
the council in relations with the
Commission and the European Parliament
it negotiates on behalf of the council
to reach agreement on legislative files
with the other EU institutions the
presidency of the Council rotates among
the EU Member States every six months
this means that each country takes it in
terms to leave the council and prepare a
six-month work programme the order of
rotation of the presidencies is set by
the council member states holding the
presidency work together in groups of
three called trios they set long-term
goals and prepare a common agenda of
topics to be addressed by the council
over an 18-month period these long term
goals are guided by the priorities
adopted by the European Council in its
strategic agenda covering for instance
jobs growth and competitiveness energy
and climate policies freedom security
and justice find out when your country
will next be leading the council and
much more on Concilium europa dot EU